hello reject nation it's Greg over here
so we're gonna check out from an awesome
awesome YouTube channel who deserves to
be way bigger than a lot of channels to
be way bigger than us I'm still so
shocked that he only has this money he
only has six thousand two hundred
seventy subs as we're filming this let's
get him to ten B he has some videos that
have like hundreds of thousands of views
and he has this new one out Avengers
infinity war retro trailer which I'm
excited to see this guy deserves to be
bigger so please subscribe to this guy's
channel immediately if you've seen his
videos before he's done like the mashups
of Justice League
Shrek Ragnarok there's some funny-ass
[ __ ] this guy does and was great yeah it
was great and patron of the day shout
out today for David Gandy give your full
shoutout I think towards the end of the
video buddy but right now let's check
out this retro style video
[Music]
and the far end of the universe
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
god Stanley what are we doing
[Music]
a vendor's saga continues infinity war
live the adventure
[Music]
tracking
[Music]
that's all group of people who don't see
you let's go to see you guys is a great
channel great great channel there's some
stuff in here I have never seen it was
there a doctor strange in the past that
because I know some of this is not like
I think when they take cha God from
Universal Soldier so this is probably
been a I think that whoever they're
using is a man I think I've seen before
from like a it's like a Japanese it's
crazy looking at all this footage that
he put together like with Thor Hulk
spider-man potato yeah I mean some of
this I don't actually recognize I don't
exactly know where Burt Reynolds is from
here I feel like an idiot for not
knowing that if I should know that from
flash to Flash Gordon ignores Punisher
at one point I was in gonna ask that I
know Dolph Lundgren I know yeah I don't
remember Chuck Norris doing that I mean
me neither I know they were making I
read an article once about them making
like a Hulk and spider-man TV yeah yeah
I mean what's crazy about this is it
puts you back in that reminder state of
Marvel used to not be successful even
the comics weren't successful back then
they began to get more successful and
then I remember like all the stories of
them trying to bring Marvel to movies
and TV and how they just kept failing
especially the cap and the Fantastic
Four that was just awful there's a
spider-man live-action show at one point
a 70s or 80s one of those eras this is
exactly why I don't think it's some fad
that's gonna die out low or whatever
some genre is gonna die alike
Spielberg's famously said because look
at how they've evolved they know how to
evolve they know how did stay up to date
a little was to watch all these I love
to watch all the old ones it would be
fun I mean I'm sure that they're they're
plucky and enjoyable in their own
and it is cool to see like they are
novel like it takes you back to the time
where yeah like comics were very
different and regarded differently and
they were still trying it even back then
and I this makes you realize not that
every clip is from a comic book related
show but it makes you realize just how
long we've been trying to do this we
talked about this on a patreon video I
feel like video game movies are the next
wave if they nail it and get it down
right because people think compact
movies is this giant wave and I'm like
well they be trying to make it away for
a very long time yeah once they got a
few down that we're amazing suddenly we
get a huge influx of them and I think
once we get I would say to at least
great video game movies we're gonna get
a sweeping amount of video tracks once
they once they have the code of like how
to make a good video game movie there's
gonna be a lot of video game movies
you're gonna try to follow that mold
eventually we'll have a heyday where
there's a cinematic universe for every
caller yeah well Darth blender I mean I
don't know how you guys managed to edit
these all together so style like so
seamlessly manda it's blends so it is a
good blend because that's one thing that
it can go wrong with a lot of these like
super cuts or trailer spoofs is it can
feel very choppy they do this such a
great thing where it feels like this
could be a real thing oh yeah he knows
like something that was ripped out of
the past and sort of this too just made
me really want to see a live-action
Swamp Thing for now yeah cuz they
borrowed Swamp Thing for group that's a
character I love to see me come back in
the now and see what the updated super
cool they're supposed to be in Justice
League dark Thank You Darth blender and
before this video wraps up shout out
today for our patron David yeah Andy
David Gandy it was so kind that we were
going through the whole troubleshooting
process of getting the channel back he
actually increased his pledge we got to
do a Google hangout with the guy it's
interesting cuz he's one of our older
patrons hence retro he's one of our
retro subscribers one of our retro peeps
I thought he would be like one of those
older guys who has like a lot to say all
the time and he's actually like a really
kind of quiet
and he has his sin sweet sincerity
honorable dude he's a guitarist he lives
in California and he's a guy with a lot
of experience under his belt he's just a
sweet humble human being and man I'm
telling you ladies an energy nice up
calm eyes if you're into older men David
Gandy he's single right now and older
guys they tend to know what they're
doing and you could tell this guy keeps
in shape if you just want to know more
information about the guns
me hands because it telling you girls a
letter away I could help you out man
David Gandy he's looking to plant his
seed young were your official dating app
David Gandy we'd ever joked like that
once with him on the Google hangout guys
you can subscribe to the real rejects
click that notification bell make sure
to check us out on patreon it's like a
second youtube channel over there uncut
and then there's some extra perks as
well for higher reward tiers follow us
there and check us out on the Stardust
app download and follow us first